alors la vallée des saints jamais allée
connu parce que c'est un parc zoologique
dédié aux primates un parc zoologique un
petit peu différent des autres parce
qu'on a que des primates qui sont en
semi liberté dans des grands enclos et
puis en fait depuis que ouvert en 98 et
depuis 98 on faisait un autre travail en
parallèle mais sur lequel on
communiquait pas c'était c'est à dire
des on était très actif dans les pays où
vivent normalement les primates dans
leur milieu naturel à travers notre
association le conservatoire pour la
protection des primates et on a eu la
chance entre guillemets d'avoir un
passionné d'animaux qui nous a légué une
grande part de son patrimoine et qui
nous a permis en fait de créer cette
cabane du colibri au sein de la vallée
des singes et cette cabane du colibri en
fait c'est la mise en lumière des
actions du conservatoire pour la
protection des primates s'est montré un
petit peu ce qu'on fait la démarche
qu'on a engagés et puis les projets
qu'on soutient à travers le à travers le
monde parce qu'on est actif dans
différents pays que ce soit en amérique
du sud en afrique madagascar et puis en
asie du sud est aussi donc toutes les
zones géographiques où vivent les
primates et où ils sont gravement
menacées par les activités humaines
il ya différents projets qui peuvent
être soutenus ça peut aller d'un projet
de conservation de conservation pur
c'est-à-dire vraiment de la mise en
place d'actions de protection sur le sur
le terrain une création de réserves par
exemple ça peut être sur la formation de
pisteur ça peut être au contraire de la
sensibilisation dans les écoles voilà on
est vraiment on est vraiment très ouvert
sur les propositions qu'on nous fait
généralement cédé on fait plus confiance
entre guillemets on va puisse s'engager
auprès de deux ressortissants du pays
même en fait ça c'est une de nos
priorités y compris dans les bourses de
recherche compte qu'on décerne deux fois
par an que son décès en déroute des
bourses comme ça aussi à des étudiants
des pays où vivent les primates pour
pouvoir justement mettre en place des
actions de conservation que ce soit de
l'éducation auprès d'enfants que ce soit
de l'aide logistique que ce soit au
contraire du renforcement juridique ça
peut être aussi ça la mise en place
vraiment de du suivi des lois
de la mise en place des lois en tout cas
l'application sur le terrain des lois la
formation des pisteurs là il ya vraiment
plein plein de plein d'actions possibles
des 98 en fait la simple petites actions
qui avouent qu'ils pouvaient être mises
en place par un simple visiteur qui
était sensible à notre cause mais
c'était de mettre quelques glisser
quelques pièces dans les tirelires qui
étaient dispersés dans le parc voilà et
puis petit à petit on leur a proposé de
nouvelles actions en 2003 on a commencé
à proposer des parrainages donc les gens
pouvaient parrainer les animaux du parc
les animaliers soigneur animalier de la
vallée des singes écrivait deux fois par
an des nouvelles du filleul voilà leur
parent il recevait des photos des choses
comme ça des informations sur l'espèce
sacré vraiment un lien vraiment
personnel en fait entre les entre les
visiteurs et certains de nos primes à un
peu plus tard en a mis en place ce qu'on
appelle animalier d'un jour un animal et
d'un jour en fait c'est une les gens
vont passer une journée entière avec le
salarié de l'association et des
soigneurs du parc et vont découvrir un
petit peu toutes les facettes du métier
d'animal y est voilà c'est pas juste
nourrir les animaux c'est pas juste
nettoyer les cages sait faire plein
d'autres activités donc on fait visiter
les coulisses on en même temps on en
profite pour faire passer des messages
bien sûr de conservation et ensuite on
peut aussi être bénévole l'été on
organise des festivals en fait en
juillet et en août des festivals sur
plusieurs jours pendant lesquels ya des
activités qui sont proposées des
activités ludiques en lien bien sûr avec
la protection des primates donc là on
peut nous aider simplement à tenir des
stands et animale animé par dompter ces
deux festivals il ya tous ces activités
là qui sont kiss kill qui nous rapporte
de l'argent et est aujourd'hui le
conservatoire en approche on approche
des 2 millions d'euros reversés à
différents projets dans le milieu
naturel donc c'est pour ça que nous on a
voulu mettre mettre en lumière un petit
peu toutes ses activités grâce à cette
salle du colibri dans la salle du
colibri en fait il ya différentes salles
voilà quiconque qui ont plusieurs
ambiances la première salle qui est un
petit peu la salle de découverte où
justement on rencontre jeanne tamarins
c'est un personnage qui est créée donc
il ya des il ya des écrans qui explique
un petit peu des écrans qui montre des
vidéos de gendt a marre on l'appelle
comme ça parce qu'il a des grandes
moustaches comme le tamarins empereurs
qui vit au brésil hier soit son petit
fils
qu'il surnomme colibri et puis lui dit
que lui il est passionné des primates et
qui participe donc on découvre les
visiteurs en fait découvre un petit peu
que les primates sont menacés simplement
ensuite dans la deuxième salle c'est le
bureau de monsieur tamarins et là on se
rend compte de toutes les menaces
vraiment qui pèse donc le sur la
déforestation
les faits les effets néfastes de la
culture en masse de l'huile de palme le
braconnage le trafic animal etc puis la
dernière salle ce sont justement les
salles des solutions qu'est ce qu'on
peut et faire pour que pour aider le
conservateur dans cette protection des
primates des singes dans le milieu
naturel et donc ont proposé ces
différentes de souscrire ces différentes
prestations que ce soit le parrainage
animalier d'un jour ou simplement de
faire un don de devenir mécène parce que
l'on est ouvert aussi bien sûr au
mécénat et des entreprises qui nous qui
nous soutiennent et qui nous offre un
petit peu de soutien soit logistique
soit financiers